[Music]
Titanus Methuselah was one of the new
Titans that were awakened big odorous
alpha call this Titan was first seen in
the movie trailers as a mountain Titan
that'll walk and had an entire ecosystem
on its back once thought to be either
Gamera or Anguirus since both of these
guys use had similar loads even though
both of them weren't so rocky looking
this new guide you are Titan is by far
one of the best new designs with a
backstory that was equally interesting
although it was not stated explicitly in
the movies the novelization of this
Titan said that Methuselah was a Titan
file in continental Europe and had an
outpost built around it by Moana outpost
67 located just outside Munich Germany
but he wasn't always in the same place
there is a story that in the medieval
age there was a very situated in the
place and there was a man who was out
for some work when he came back instead
of finding home there was instead a
mountain keep this in mind that this
place was a playing area a sort of a
valley the theories that Titanus
Methuselah was awakened by another Titan
in the past and had to relocate himself
till he found a sweet spot and stayed
there for centuries
Titus Matthias Methuselah is a portable
Titan with a forest on his armored shell
it was us large white eyes and a mouth
full of large teeth he also has large
horns growing down from the top of his
head and curved inwards although a part
of it Methuselah height is around 100
meters and is comparable to that of the
bipedal Godzilla but his internal volume
exceeds that of Godzilla as does his
overall length and mass this renders
Methuselah the largest heaviest Titan
under current Moana observation his
spines ran along his back and his
reptilian tail
he has claws for front feet and hooves
for back feet which could see a lot
about the nature of the monster this
Titans main attack mode is to RAM
himself against the opponent much like a
bull which would also tell us that his
skin is to say and durable as seen when
he was unfazed by the attacks from the
military when he was rampaging over
Munich in conjunction with his immense
mass Methuselah durability has
estimated to be on par with or even
greater than that of Godzilla himself
millennia of evolution has culminated in
a body covered with thick rock like
scales whose density is impossible to
what I would call in technology the name
Methuselah was given to him and it was
taken out of a character in the Bible
this character was the oldest known
biblical figure in terms of age his H
was 969 yes almost a thousand years old
which would give us two ideas about how
Moana came about with that name Heda
he was discovered by the medieval
Germanic tribes in 969 ad but that he
was the oldest of all the Titans
analysis of such painting supplemented
by carbon dating of samples has revealed
that Methuselah is the oldest idol and
demonic observation it is estimated that
he predates both Godzilla and monster
zero by several thousand years
Methuselah was one of the 17 Titans
awakened by monster zero signal
following Godzilla's near death by the
explosion of the oxygen destroyer weapon
rising up from his containment area at
mana outpost sixty-seven he was met with
immediate bombardment from tanks jets
and artillery none of them which faced
him to the slightest the old Titan
immediately became rampaging across
Munich reducing the entire city to
smoldering rubble before change it goes
to Boston Brussels have activated the
orko device and all the awaken Titus
were now converging on her location the
battle was long over by the time
Methuselah's arrival chunks of vidura's
flesh littered the city and standing
over them was the hulking form of
Godzilla himself
knocking eyes with a triumphant Godzilla
Methuselah bow down and submission later
in the credits scene it was seen that
all the new Titans were converging
towards Skull Island and he probably
would have followed suit although how he
would have crossed over thousands of
kilometers of ocean is the right
question be sure to LIKE share and
subscribe for more videos and do click
on a notification bell for more regular
and actual notifications